[Music]
my name is Sandy I am a product manager
for Google Cloud databases um and with
me today I have rvy Mory uh senior
director of engineering for databases at
Google cloud and we're so excited to be
joined by Christopher executive director
head of data stores and B engineering of
the CME Group I want to kick us off
today we're going to have a really great
session for you guys starting with a
quick introduction of alloy DB we
launched alloy DB at Google IO last year
and it's been a really awesome Journey
since going to GA last December and I'll
talk about it give you a quick intro
again
today then we're going to go see alloy
DB in action talk to Christopher about
his experience at CME Group using alloy
DB and then rvy and I are going to dive
under the hood and then finally we're
going to talk about getting there things
like migrations our partner programs Etc
and what's next how you can get started
and some great other sessions for you to
attend there we go okay introducing allv
a postgress compatible database that way
only Google can deliver
it okay before we jump into what alloy
DB is I want to talk really briefly
about why alloy DB was was built by
Google and that's because we've been
seeing customers as they migrate to the
cloud uh approach their legacy
proprietary databases differently for
databases like Oracle SQL server db2 and
more we're not seeing as many customers
want to do like for like migrations
instead they're using the excuse of
moving to the cloud as an excuse to um
modernize their database estate and um
move to standardized open- Source
Solutions and there's one database in
particular that we see emerging Above
the Rest and and that's post
cross and so why are developers and
Enterprises actually choosing postgress
we think there are a couple reasons why
this is a really great ecosystem it's
open source you get all of the
portability that you wouldn't didn't
have before really simple license
management and it's super cost-
effective it has Rich functionality that
can compete with a lot of great
Enterprise databases on the market
including an extensible architecture
that amazing ecosystem of extensions and
it's built to scale and of course it's
proven across millions of users in
almost every industry and has a really
great friendly
community at the same time what we hear
from customers is that sometimes those M
migrations can be hard hard especially
if you're re-platforming from a
commercial grade database but even
sometimes if you're running open source
postgress at scale and so some of the
pain points we've heard at gcp for
customers running postr are really
around scale performance and
availability but as we talk to customers
they are also excited about new
opportunities to as they move to the
cloud opportunities to ease their
management overhead and to access new t
or to build new types of user
experiences like real-time operational
insights or integrating more
sophisticated AIML capabilities into
their
applications and so to do that we
introduced alloy DB a new open-source
compatible database engine ready for top
tier relational database workloads a lot
of folks over the year I guess that
we've been we've been live have asked me
why did we name it alloy DB and it comes
from the it comes from chemistry the
idea that you take the these two
products and when you put them together
when you take these two different
elements and put them together you make
something stronger and I think that's
what we've done here with alloy DB you
take postgress compatibility again a
database and ecosystem that we really
love and combine it with some of the
best of Google that infrastructure that
helps us scale offer better performance
and better
availability some of the most exciting
things about allb are its performance
numbers it is four times faster than
standard postc cross for transactional
workloads and actually that's measured
on a 16 vcpu instance as you can see
here on a 64 we actually see even more
performance benefit because alloy DB can
really take advantage of those larger
machine shapes and this helps not just
with your Topline performance but it can
help with things like price performance
as well because sometimes you can run
workloads using your alloy DB instance
on smaller amounts of
resources and it's up to a hundred times
faster for analytical queries than
standard postgress you know here's an
example of a query that on postgress
takes over a minute to run and on alloy
DB takes less than a second so when we
have this type of huge performance
benefit on analytical queries that
doesn't just change your application
performance it changes the types of
queries you can run because the reality
is you're never run running a query in
your application that takes a minute but
half a second you can build experiences
on
that okay so just to recap allb was
meant to deliver a commercial grade
experience without the costs and without
the vendor lockin in addition to some of
these performance benefits and I'm going
to talk about that last one the replica
lag in a little bit it's also highly
available with a 49 SLA inclusive of
Maintenance highly scalable with
scaleout storage horizontal scaling of
reads and vertical scaling of Rights and
it's intelligent with autopilot
capabilities and embedded AIML to make
management easy but also with some tools
and capabilities that allowed you to
build generative AI applications on top
of it and of course it's fully postrest
compatible making it easy to move to
easy to run uh you can really truly
treat it like postr and it has
predictable transparent
pricing
and with that I'm going to transfer over
to Christopher to talk about his
experience at CME thank you
Sandy and thank you for inviting me to
this conversation today and thank
everybody for joining I know I I've
looked at this list of sessions here at
next and they're all
fantastic and so you've chosen to spend
your time with us and uh thank you for
that um so just a quick introduction
introduction to to the Chicago mertile
Exchange um Chicago mertile Exchange or
CME was formed in 1898 as the uh butter
and egg board uh it expanded over the
preceding decades to include a number of
additional agricultural products and um
by the 1970s the CME had revolutionized
markets um by providing uh Futures
against interest rates other Financial
elements and so with that let's talk
about our journey at CME to the cloud
and in particular to gcp and the
important role that alloy DB plays in
our
transformation
apologies okay so we have a clear vision
of what we're trying to achieve and
that's really providing modern Analytics
uh and truly great data experiences
internally into our customers but thate
presents a couple of different
challenges for us um the CME over the
years has modernized its technology
stack several times first starting with
a legacy monolithic architecture and
then moving into more of a distributed
systems to take advantage of new
components and new architectures to
enhance our systems well now we're
making an equally significant um change
here at the CME which is adopting cloud
and adopting Cloud specifically to
provide us the velocity that we're
looking for that we need that our
customers need to bring those really
great data
experiences well there are some
challenges there and one of those is as
part of the transformation to
distributed computing inside of the CME
the CME has leveraged proprietary
vertically integrated database
technology in order to achieve the
Velocity in our database subsystems that
the markets
demand and I'll just go ahead and say it
that that that proprietary integrated
database technology is Oracle exad
data um we also are working closely with
our partners at Google to address some
of the unique requirements that the
financial services industry and our
markets have you know it's all great to
move to the cloud but we have to ensure
and create the guard rails
necessary to keep our data and our
customers data confidential and
secure and then the finally there's one
other challenge that we have in the
database space and that's our people and
our
processes um you know our application
developer Community have been working
with tools uh like pipelines continuous
integration continuous deployment
uh for a while now but our database
engineering and our database
Administration teams because of the
nature of the technology that we've been
working with haven't always gotten into
that space and so as part of this we are
upskilling our database engineering
teams to be more in line with a
cloud-based and uh devops
culture
so one of these challenges that we have
is that the Oracle exit dat platform
provides a very high level of
performance um and we need to understand
before we start architecting the
processes and actually migrating our
database applications to the cloud we
have to understand fundamentally first I
is this going to accommodate our needs
um will it be performant enough and
support the latency requirements and the
throughput requirements that we have
supporting our applications
today and so in order to accomplish that
we developed inhouse a database testing
and benchmarking framework now it is uh
I would say inspired by an oracle
feature called real application testing
but we've baked in the flexibility to
enable us to run benchmarks to run
functionality tests against various
other platforms and compare those back
to our Legacy database
infrastructure and we've done this
against a number of key critical
workloads within the firm the workload
that I'd like to highlight for you today
in particular is a clearing system it's
a critical clearing system involved in
the clearing process and one of the
reasons that I want to highlight this
for you today is because it illustrates
also an impact of having leveraged these
proprietary database platforms like
exadata and that's that we have a hybrid
workload here we're not just tuning for
fast transactions and oltp usage we also
have analytical queries that the users
can execute against the system through
the user interface and so this partic
this presents a particular uh challenge
when we're trying to find and leverage
fit forp purpose uh database Platforms
in the
cloud and let me just let the cat out of
the bag a little bit early here um the
alloy DB tests were fantastic uh in our
particular proof of concept that we did
against this clear ing system alloy DB
performed very well against the
transactional queries our oldp use case
in many cases uh it performed
better and uh even with the analytical
queries that we run against the system
we found that many of them are keeping
up with the demands of the application
there are a few exceptions and we'll
talk about
those all right now to kind of get into
the detail
of the performance uh benchmarking that
we've done for Alloy
DB um so this represents one of our
replays that we're using our in-house
tool um to effectively simulate real
production workload that we pulled off
of uh one of the live production
systems and in virtually every case we
found alloy DB is meeting the
transactional
requirements of uh of of our application
there were a few exceptions those are
those 197 olop UI queries uh that did
take longer on Allo DB but I think that
this just underscores the necessity of
good design when you're working with
relational
databases um in in this particular case
the application would allow the user to
pick an arbitrary number of columns and
apply an arbitrary number of filters to
get the answer that they're looking for
and you know I'm sure there are database
administrators out here in the crowd and
as you may know that's a very very
difficult problem to solve
for and now let's talk about some of the
outcome some of the learnings that we
had um through these performance tests
and stress tests against the alloy DB
instances um one of the first things
that I want to mention here this is just
something that occurred to me a while
back I love Google's approach to
database Engineering in the cloud as
Sandy mentioned postgress is emerging
for a number of reasons as the
open-source database of choice for
Google Cloud for many Cloud providers um
due to its flexibility its license
strategy uh feature parody with Oracle
in many cases and so what Google's doing
here is they're engineering fit for
purpose uh uh services so you may start
with something like cloudsql postgress
it's great for mid-range workloads it's
very cost effective and then you may
reach a point where you just simply need
a higher level of performance a lower
latency out of your database operations
or possibly a higher level of of of of a
availability and then Cloud spanner is
there to support your geod distributed
workloads but the point that I'm making
here is that from the outside they all
taste like postgress and so that enables
you to use a common set of drivers a
common SQL language and dialect and also
a common set of tools against a very
wide array of use cases alloy DB being
one of
those another key finding that we have
here is we found 80% actually more than
80% of our workloads don't actually
require the level of response time the
performance that's offered by the Oracle
exadata
platform um I think consolidation is
natural it makes sense and when you buy
into a technology like Oracle exadata
for a few of your workloads it's only
very natural to use the rest of your
capacity to consolidate onto that and
that has an effect unto itself and
that's that it creates a very tightly
coup coupled data layer that we're now
working to unravel here at the
CME um a few other quick points because
of the architecture of postgress and
alloy by proxy uh you may be allocating
more sessions in your application to
take advantage of things like read pools
where you can horizontally scale your
reads across a pool of
replicas uh while isolating your read
write primary so that may require some
additional sessions in your application
layer to accommodate that but generally
speaking it's well worth
it the other thing that I'll mention is
that if you're looking at your database
transactions at an atomic level you may
need a bit more
CPU um that's fine in most
cases and then finally we've all many of
us have worked on cloud-based databases
before and you know you're trying to
achieve a particular level of iops in
order order to support your workload
well with many Cloud providers that has
an effect and that effect is your over
allocating storage you know on one hand
as a database administrator it's great
I'm never going to run out of storage
but there's a real cost associated with
that and so that's one of the patterns
that alloy DB here is working to break
is that no longer are we required to
allocate orders of magnitude more
storage than we require for a particular
workload just to achieve our IOP
Target and then now I'm going to pass
the mic over to Ravi here who's going to
get into the guts of alloy DB and talk
about some of the features all right
thank you Christopher so now uh let's
look at a little bit behind the scenes
of what is actually driving the kind of
performance and the the amazing things
that Sandy spoke about so Sandy and I
will uh do a little peek under the hood
yeah let's do
it all right the fundamental principle
that ALB is built on is this notion of
disaggregation of comput and storage so
you've got the database layer that's a
set of compute nodes and they're all
talking to a storage layer that is
disaggregated completely so what
disaggregation means is now you can
scale the database layer completely
independent of uh the storage nodes um
and the storage nodes are able to
balance the load and give you a very
cost effective and a very predictable
performance so the key Point here is
thanks to this complete disaggregation
architecture each of the layers can
scale very independently based on your
workload and so jumping into the storage
layer what's really cool about this is
that we have an intelligent database
storage designed and optimized for
postrest as you can see here it's a
regional storage service spanning
multiple zones and as Ry mentioned it's
disaggregated itself so you have compute
resources in the storage layer
completely separate from durable storage
which is based on Google's distributed
file system Colossus when we talked
about some of those performance benefits
at the beginning you know especially
that 4X right throughput uh or sorry the
4X transactional performance a lot of
that is driven by this storage
architecture because you have an
architecture that powers fast
predictable performance eliminating IO
bottlenecks and offloading work from the
primary to the storage
service it can also help with things
like availability and uh read replica
lag which Ry is going to talk about
right now all right so one of the things
that the storage engine architecture
gives you is the ability for many read
instances to attach to the same exact
storage engine so this we alloy DB
supports the concept of read pools which
is the notion of a single reader
endpoint behind which you can have even
up to 20 read uh
instances and what this endpoint gives
you is a very easy way to do horizontal
scaling of your read connections so as
Christopher was talking about based on
the workload you can add new read
instances very easily and very cheaply
without doing any data copy so you've
got the ability to dynamically adapt
your your cluster and the amount of
compute based on your workload and
that's both up and down so you can for
Price spin it up yeah and when you don't
need it very easy to spin it down the
other thing that read pools give you is
this ability to handle your read
workloads without having any impact on
the primary so you get complete
isolation between your read workloads
and your primary transaction
workload um also these replicas and read
instances are typically very low lag
what it means is it's tracking almost in
real time what the view of the primary
instance is and typically we look at
something in the small single digit
millisecond lag uh and and this is
something that we've taken even further
recently with a bunch of innovations
that we've done in the way the logs are
transported and applied on the replica
that results in a even lower lag and the
point of this low lag replicas is now it
really opens up the door for a wide
variety of reporting analytics use cases
that was much much harder to do before
this
definitely so let's actually look at
some numbers and here you've got uh two
uh benchmarks that we're showing here
and it shows how alloy DB compares to
stock postris so on the left we've got a
workload which is a high transaction
throughput workload running on the
primary but the read replica is idle and
in this particular case the replica lag
with all DB is 25 times lower compared
to stock post
on the right hand is uh even more
interesting use case where in addition
to the high throughput transaction
workload on the primary you also have a
read workload happening on the replica
in this particular case stock postgress
uh many times ends up with unbounded lag
just simply because the replica is not
able to keep up with the primary but
what we've done in allb thanks to a
bunch of really uh clever Innovations is
you always have bounded lag and and
that's really awesome as you can see
here yeah I mean like the point of read
replicas right is to do reads on them
and so what's really cool about this is
it allows you to use all of your
resources to the max while still keeping
your replica lag in very manageable
levels one of my favorite features about
alloy DB is the super fast failover we
thought really hard about how to make
alloy DB a highly available service and
that means a high availability for both
unplanned and planned types of downtime
that we take so in the unplanned case
alloy DB has very fast bounded failover
that's independent of database size and
load and of course an RPO of zero that
means no datab no data loss on failover
you can see a quick diagram of how it
works here with a primary and a failover
replica and a single read write IP that
way you're not having to um manage
multiple different IPS you'll use the
same endpoint to connect to the failover
in in the case where you have
to what I'm I'm really excited about is
uh we recently launched actually thanks
to feedback from CME uh a new fault
injection API for ha testing so uh you
can make sure through testing that your
application failover is as smooth as
your database failover is with that is
really cool
yeah and then finally we wanted to make
maintenance easy again one of the most
common sources of downtime are is
actually the downtime that we plan for
both us at Google when we do Google
initiated maintenance and you guys when
you do things like instance resizes or
sometimes change flags that require
restart with allb our goal is to make
these non-disruptive operations and so
we have in addition to our primary when
we're doing maintenance we're going to
spin up a replacement Primary in the
same Zone and coordinate maintain the
replacement primary and then coordinate
a handoff from Storage after the
replacement primary becomes your
original your new
primary again a really new feature we
launched recently is now this happens
with less than one second of downtime
for most workloads on the primary and
again zero seconds of downtime on the
read replicas that means you're able to
reconnect right away a huge improvement
from just a year ago when we were at 10
seconds exactly so this really makes
this truly zero down time extremely
highly available and you can use it for
the most Mission critical of your
applications yeah all right um switching
a little bit from the database storage
layer up into the compute yeah um when
you see the architecture here um what
you see is that the database layer is
really an highly optimized postris
Engine with built-in tiers of caching
including RAM memory based caching as
well as uh an ultra fast cache that we
use for extremely low latency of uh data
access now in addition to the standard
row based uh caching that postris comes
with alloy DB has also introduced a new
column oriented format and I'll talk a
little bit about that in a second and
the point is both of these types of
formats are automatically and
dynamically handled by the database no
need for any application changes and the
database just figures out exactly what's
the right format for the data based on
your workload and puts it into the
appropriate tier of the cache so
everything is automatic and you get the
transparent benefits of
this so what is columnar good for it it
turns out it's actually really really
good for certain classes of analytical
reporting type of queries that have to
scan a lot of data so what we've done in
alloy DB is introduced this new columnar
engine that sits alongside the road
based engine of postgress and does the
right thing transparently So based on
the workload it converts the data into
the columnar format and the columnar
engine works on it using a highly
state-of-the-art if I will uh type of an
engine using things like vectorized
execution Bloom filters and and a number
of other techniques to have the highest
possible performance that you can get uh
with that type of query processing uh so
we support vectorized execution of
things like filters and Aggregates and
now recently we also added uh vectorized
joints which now opens up to another
large class of workloads that can be
handled by the columnar engine um we're
also spilling it out into the ultra fast
cache so you can handle much larger data
set sizes and uh last but not the least
we're constantly adding support for more
data types in the columnar engine based
on a lot of feedback that we get from
our early customers and uh the result of
all of this is depending on your
workload you can get one two orders of
magnitude higher performance with the
columnar engine
awesome U Switching gears a little bit I
want to very briefly touch on uh a set
of features that we call the autopilot
and this is based on our U thing of how
do we make alloy DB very very easy to
manage very easy to operate and so
there's a set of features under the
autopilot umbrella and I'm just going to
talk about three very briefly um so the
first autopilot feature that I want to
talk about is this thing called the
index advisor um so as the name suggests
what it's doing is based on your
workload it can give you a set of
recommendations of what is the best set
of indexes for your workload U it uses
uh state-of-the-art AIML techniques to
do this with very very low impact on
your system in terms of both storage and
and CPU um and the result we've done a
lot of benchmarking on a wide variety of
workloads obviously your mileage will
vary depending on your workload but on
on the thing that you see here which is
a real world uh customer workload the
index advisor recommended indexes that
give you a 4X better query performance
now of course with indexes you also have
to worry about the DML performance and
the cost of maintaining those indexes
but it's one of those things that can
really make your job of operating this
large databases with a lot of tables lot
of queries and things that keep changing
all the time just let the machine tell
you how best to optimize it what's
really cool about this one for me is
that it's columnar aware which means
that it helps you leverage these
different features for speeding up
queries in the way that's best for your
workload and again in all cases you know
no schema changes no exactly
exactly another uh quick uh autopilot
feature that I want to talk about is on
memory management this is something that
all database administrators really know
uh that one of the things that you
really have to tune is how much memory
you give to the buffer cache of the
database
and there's a problem that if you don't
get it exactly right either you end up
with out of memory errors which have to
restart the database U or you end up
leaving performance on the table so what
we've done with alloy DB is to say okay
let the system figure it out so we've
got this thing called the Adaptive
memory management that based on the
workload Uh current workload at that
moment in time it's dynamically able to
use more memory or less memory but what
it guarantees is that you will not run
into outof memory errors so it's able to
monitor how much memory each of the
backends is taking and it'll make sure
that one bad backend or misbehaving back
end is not going to bring down your
entire database and that's a huge
valuable uh uh addition for folks who
have to operate this database and ensure
the highest level of
availability and last but not the least
uh another autopilot feature that we
have worked on is this thing called
adaptive vacuum management um vacuuming
is a very common problem that uh many
postgress folks are familiar are know
exactly what I'm talking about um and
and not getting it right can have a
disastrous Consequence the database can
really be down hard but what we've done
with alloy DB again in the spirit of
autopilot and Auto uh managing has done
this thing called adaptive and automatic
vacuum management that guarantees that
you just can like not stop worrying
about it and the database automatically
figures out how much resources to give
to vacuuming to ensure that you won't
run into transaction ID exhaustion um
and if need be it adds more resources
for vacuuming and throttles back the
transaction ID consumption so lots more
uh will go into this autopilot umbrella
but this is on our path of just making
aidb completely automatic and completely
uh hands off driving if you will and
like again when we talk about these
autopilot Fe features it's really easy
to focus oh oh it makes management easy
but actually when we look at things that
customers really care about availability
performance it can have a huge impact
you know one of the largest sources of
downtime for customers running post
cross on gcp are out of disc errors and
out of memory errors and so with the
automated memory management you're going
to avoid those even though we all hope
that we can do it ourselves S A little
better huge and then you know storage
scales up automatically and drop a table
scales right back
down okay so we talked a little bit
about these autopilot features the way
that we use Ai and other adaptive
algorithms to make management of the
database easy for you but we know that
you guys are also hoping to use AI to
build more um interesting interactive
experiences with your customers and so
today in the keynote uh Brad announced
alloy DB aai it's an integrated
collection of features meant to help you
as developers better integrate AI into
your applications and leverage your
real-time operational data to work with
llms and build cooler
experiences that includes three parts
the first is um high performance highs
scale Vector queries uh a couple months
ago we launched support for the PG
Vector extension and now we're
introducing 10 times f faster Vector
queries and support for four times
larger Vector Dimensions um again to
support a wider array of workloads but
to also make sure that we can meet your
performance needs that's due to tight
Integrations with alloy DB's query
processing
engine we also offer easy embeddings
generation uh you know alloy DB allows
you to bring your own embeddings if you
would like to and generate them wherever
you are but if you're just getting
started with Vector embeddings we also
have a nice easy function for you to
create embeddings in the database itself
based on your operational data and
finally we offer integration with AI
tools that includes open source tools
like Lan chain via the postgress
connector it also includes Integrations
with uh vertex AI if you were here in
this last talk they just introduced
vertex AI extensions we're super excited
about that and looking forward to
integrating alloy
DB and then finally this is a feature we
actually launched um I think last year
but the ability to call a Vertex a model
directly from the database uh super
powerful feature so you can call any
model that's hosted in Vex aai right
from inside the database pre-trained
models or custom models yeah amazing
cool okay I'm going to talk about
getting there so uh I'm going to zoom
quickly so that we have time for Q&A but
um thank you so much rvy uh I'm GNA talk
about getting there and um how how we
can help you get from wherever you are
to alloy
DB so again our investment in Google
cloud is to make database migrations
easier than
ever and one of the ways we do that is
via our database migration service which
now makes homogeneous migrations from
postgress wherever you're running it to
alloy DB easier and faster
but we've also introduced database
migration service to support Oracle to
postc cross migrations today that's
available on cloud SQL but coming very
soon to alloy DB and again if you were
at the keynote this morning you saw one
of our really cool new features the
ability to leverage duet AI to do code
conversion to help with the last mile of
that
migration and then finally we have uh an
amazing program with partners for f if
you're looking for folks to help help
you along the way there are certified
Solutions and certified partners that
know how to work with alloy DB that can
make your journey easier and so we have
a lot of the tools but I actually wanted
to bring Christopher back on stage to
talk about his experience and what he
used uh actually I'll I'll I'll I'll
drive for you thank you s hello again um
so earlier I talked about our first
problem which is is there a cloud-based
database that can keep up with our
transactional throughput and latency
requirements to support the exchange the
second problem is how do we get there at
scale and so what we have internally is
a program we refer to as the DB
refactory and it's designed to solve a
couple of problems one is our appdev
community they're very busy they have
full backlogs their engineering features
that the exchange needs and so working
our way into a backlog to say hey folks
let's pause for a second and refactor
your entire application for a new
database platform that's a tall order
and so with this DB refactory program we
do a couple of things uh we start with
schema conversion and embedded database
object conversion we use a couple of
tools